Gabrielle SIERRA: Hey everyone - I am so happy
to report that our show has been nominated for
a Webby! And we’re super honored to
be recognized alongside such amazing
podcasts BUT we’d be even more honored
if we won! So if you could vote for us,
head over to vote.webbyawards.com and vote for
Why It Matters. Thanks! On with the show.
The news is our connection to the world.
Whether you wake up and listen to a podcast
or grab a morning paper, journalists are
responsible for the information you use to
form an accurate picture of the world.
It’s an easy thing to take for granted.
But as authoritarian populism surges worldwide,
journalism has become an increasingly dangerous
profession - and populations are losing their
access to the news they need. Nowhere is this
trend more dramatic than in Latin America,
especially in our closest neighbor Mexico,
which has become one of the most dangerous
places on Earth for reporting the news.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It Matters.
Today, vanishing press freedom in Latin America,
and the global assault on the news.
Gabrielle SIERRA:
What do you think is a healthy relationship
between the government and journalism? Because
it feels like there's this natural antagonism
there, but when does it get unhealthy?
Carin ZISSIS: It gets unhealthy when we start
to see people in high levels of government
attack journalists verbally. Because if
people at very high levels of government
start criticizing the press, calling into
question journalists and journalism, what
we find is that then that trickles down to other
levels of government and it becomes the norm.
SIERRA: This is Carin Zissis, editor-in-chief of
AS/COA Online, the website of the Americas Society
and Council of the Americas. She is also a veteran
reporter on Mexican and Latin American affairs.
ZISSIS: It starts to become the norm to doubt,
question, criticize, attack journalists, and then
that leads to actual violence against journalists.
Then that becomes part of authoritarian control,
because you're preventing a questioning of what
the government is doing. It's really a starting
point for democratic decay.
Jan-Albert HOOTSEN:
I do believe that both in Mexico and
beyond on a global level journalism
is becoming more dangerous.
SIERRA: This is Jan-Albert Hootsen,
a veteran reporter who is also the Mexico
representative for the Committee to Protect
Journalists. This means he monitors press freedom
in the region and helps reporters at risk.
HOOTSEN: There is a tendency globally
to increasingly target anybody who might
be involved in making information publicly
available that will touch on the interests of
very powerful players. They might be state.
They might be non-state. But in general,
the journalists and human rights defenders are
becoming more legitimate targets. We're also
dealing with the reality of changing technologies
and increased surveillance, often illegal,
of reporters. And I think that also makes it more
dangerous, both for journalists and for sources.
I think what we're seeing is the very logical, if
not unfortunate, consequence of a media landscape
that has been changing at a very staggering
rate. Over the past, say, twenty to thirty
years with the arrival of the internet, with the
arrival of social media, with the arrival of a new
kind of populism amongst politicians that largely
derives much of its appeal from these new ways of
communication. And it has exposed journalism to
a new kind of scrutiny that didn't exist before.
SIERRA: In the case of Latin America, some
of this scrutiny has been put into writing. A
spate of recent laws have been aimed at silencing
reporters. In 2021, Nicaraguan President Daniel
Ortega approved a law forcing media outlets
to register as “foreign agents,” giving the
government near-total oversight of their spending
and political activities. That same year,
a sweeping bill was passed in Ecuador that
criminalized the act of publishing digital content
about a person without their consent. Changes
like these target some of the basic tools that
journalists need in order to do their job.
HOOTSEN:
Mexico has always been an extremely difficult
country for the press. The country was ruled
for approximately 70 years as a one-party state.
So for the press during those 70 years in the
twentieth century, when the modern press as we
know it was largely shaped and created, the press
in Mexico had to make a choice: either they became
part of that political complex, meaning that they
would become basically a mouthpiece of the party
in power, or they would become independent and
by being free media they would be exposed to all
kinds of threats and pressures. As Mexico became a
democracy or at least a partial democracy in 2000.
There was an explosion in independent journalism
and independent media which was unfortunately soon
caught up by two realities. One of them being the
economic reality. Mexico is a country where it is
extremely difficult for a news outlet to survive
because if you're independent, you're not going to
get a lot of government advertisement. The other
aspect which makes journalism increasingly
difficult is the extreme violence against
reporters which started rising in the 1990s and
really exploded when Mexico informally launched
the “war on drugs” which is very notorious
on an international level right now.
SIERRA: By the numbers, Latin America is
consistently ranked as one of the deadliest
regions in the world for reporters, with 30
journalists killed just last year. And within
Latin America, Mexico is the most dangerous
country of all. In 2021, 664 attacks were
documented against the press there. And in 2022,
nearly 40 percent of journalists killed in Latin
America died in Mexico. Their deaths have been
attributed to a mix of gang violence, political
corruption, and a lack of arrests and prosecution
for dangerous criminals. Only Ukraine - a country
in the middle of a desperate war - saw more
journalist deaths than Mexico in 2022.
Al Jazeera English: Over the past few decades
the country’s violence and corruption has meant
journalists face attacks from everywhere.
CBS News: 2022 has been one of the deadliest
years ever for journalists in Mexico.
Al Jazeera: Intimidation, imprisonment,
harassment, and assassinations.
ZISSIS: In
spite of being a democracy, in spite of
being a country that's not currently at war,
it is the most dangerous country in the world for
journalists. If we really look at the numbers,
this increase in violence against
journalists began with the start
of Mexico's offensive on cartels. Since that
point, more than 125 journalists have died.
There was a very important election in 2018
in which Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador won the
presidency, and he came in with this huge
mandate. He won by a landslide and he's
sustained popularity over time. And at the
same time it's coincided with a questioning
of democratic institutions. So the press
being a key example of that. But we also
have an issue of what's happening in addition
around, for example, the electoral agency in
Mexico. The current government is trying to find
ways to decrease its funding and to weaken some
aspects of the INE, the electoral agency here.
Just like the United States, Mexico's going to
have another presidential election in 2024.
SIERRA: In 2022, President Andres Manuel Lopez
Obrador aka AMLO, threatened members of the
Supreme Court, reduced checks and balances,
and tightened his grip on political
power. That same year, violence
against journalists hit an all time high.
According to the Economist’s Democracy Index
report, Mexico is now considered a ‘hybrid
regime,’ walking the line between a flawed
democracy and a full-fledged authoritarian
state. And after the past four and a half
years of extreme press censorship and
backsliding, the outlook for Mexican
journalists is growing more and more grim.
ZISSIS: Now the problem keeps getting worse.
2022 was the deadliest year on record. And
we've seen this rise in violence against
journalists since the start of the Lopez Obrador
administration. It's been over time. It's to such
a degree that the president starts every day
with a press conference that goes on for a
couple of hours. It allows him to set the agenda
for what people are going to talk about in the
country. And there is a segment in his, what we
call the mañanera, the daily press conference,
called “Quién es Quién en las Mentiras,” it's the
who's who in the lying, who's who of the liars.
And during the segment in his press conference,
they actually put on a big screen pictures of
columnists, journalists, critics of the government
and try to discredit their comments and their
reporting or their coverage or their columns,
talking about things that are going on.
El Universal: “Quién es quién en las mentiras de
la semana,” así se va a llamar. “Quién es quién en
las mentiras de la semana.”
ZISSIS:
It's almost like a kind of blacklisting.
What then happens is these same journalists
then start to receive attacks. They start to
receive attacks online. Really frightening
attacks. Sometimes they get followed.
There have been all kinds of stories. So,
it's really quite scary. In December there was
an attack on a very high profile journalist in
Mexico named Ciro Gómez Leyva. When it
happens to someone who is so well known,
such a prominent journalist. It really sent
a message to journalists across the country,
this is what can happen to you. And he was someone
who had been under attack by the AMLO government.
And in fact after the attack, AMLO suggested that
maybe the attack was carried out just to make
the government look bad, as though it were a fake
attack. So, it creates these narratives of what's
true and what's false. Let's blur the lines, let's
make it confusing. So, it really can create this
atmosphere where this type of violence occurs.
SIERRA: Populists and authoritarian leaders are
natural enemies of the press. And in order to
consolidate power, most of these leaders feel they
have to crack down on journalists. It’s something
that is playing out all over the world.
For example, since his term began in 2010,
Hungary’s Prime Minister, Viktor Orbán,
has effectively dismantled press freedom.
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan of Turkey
has also shaped the news to his advantage -
his country has one of the poorest ratings
for press freedom as well as some of the highest
numbers of incarcerated journalists in the world.
And in the Philippines, former President Rodrigo
Duterte threatened journalists during his rule by
saying they’re ‘not exempt from assassination.’
The playbook goes all the way back to the fascist
leaders of the 20th century, and even earlier.
Lopez Obrador, for all his individual quirks,
is part of a long and dark tradition.
ZISSIS: I think a really important reason
that we have to pay attention to what's happening
in Mexico is because it serves as a warning. It
serves as a warning in terms of what happens
if there are attacks on the press. Certainly
Mexico is a younger democracy. It has weaker
institutions, and it shows really what happens
when you do weaken those institutions, when you do
have an erosion of institutions. And when we see
the violence in a country just across the border
having record numbers of journalists getting
killed at a time of criticism of the press, at
this time of eroding protections for the press,
it's something that we can't just ignore. It's a
warning of what will happen if we do. And freedom
of the press is a key part of democracy.
SIERRA: So, you say it’s a warning - are you
seeing similar dynamics unfold here in the U.S.?
ZISSIS: I think something that we've seen in
recent years in the United States is a questioning
of the press. We hear language around “the
mainstream media does this” or “only covers that.”
And we've seen high level government officials,
including even, obviously, President Trump,
be very vocal in attacking the press and
coming after journalists. And really
kind of vilifying the press in a new
way. Some of the language that we have heard
is really reminiscent of the type of threats
you hear against the press in other countries.
SIERRA: Okay, so we are seeing some international
themes here, but zooming back in on Mexico,
is there anything unique that we’re seeing
there? Are these dynamics different than what
you’re seeing in the rest of Latin America?
ZISSIS: Mexico has some of the same challenges
we see in other parts of Latin America in that,
because there has been this history, particularly
when Mexico wasn't really a democracy,
of journalists sometimes getting paid off,
and a system in which journalists were in a
way part of that system of maintaining this semi
authoritarian situation. We have similarities in
other parts of Latin America, but the problem
with the fact that that was in the past is that
the current government now tries to recall that
memory. There's actually a word for it in Mexico,
you're called a “chayotero,” that's a journalist
who is thought to be bought off by officials or
bought off in some way, bribed in some way
in terms of its coverage. I think what we're
seeing is a general increase in attacks in Latin
America and murders. And unfortunately that means
this model that we've seen in Mexico of attacks on
the press, verbal attacks on press, it's something
that can carry over into other countries and
that has carried over into other countries.
HOOTSEN: Everything that is happening in
Mexico nowadays, whether it's economical,
whether it's to do with drug violence
or whether it's to do with politics
is in one way or another connected to the outside
world. So press freedom is the same thing. Press
freedom in a single country never just exists
in a vacuum. It's part of a regional or even a
global development. You know, we've talked about
populism. We've talked about the way politicians
are dealing with politicians everywhere around
the globe, they will be copying each other.
I think a good example here in Latin America
is Nayib Bukele, the president of El Salvador,
extremely popular, also extremely authoritarian
president who is democratically elected but is now
trying to erode the democracy in his country.
CBS Evening News: The country with the highest
murder rate in the world for young
people under the age of 19.
Vice News: The whole question of public safety
in El Salvador hinges around who controls the
territory. Is it the gangs or is it the state?
France 24 English: The focus falls on El
Salvador’s President... Nayib Bukele.
France 24 English: He’s very controversial,
very popular in his country, but also criticized
for endangering democracy in El Salvador.
SIERRA: El Salvador is a small country of just
6.5 million people, and is not usually thought
of as a top concern for U.S. policy makers.
But in recent years, dire conditions there
have led to a massive outflow of migrants, with
nearly 2.5 million El Salvadorians now living in
the United States. The country’s leader, Nayib
Bukele, is one of the youngest heads of state
in Latin America. And since taking office,
he has leveraged his immense popularity to
crack down on press freedom in the country.
HOOTSEN: And he does so by copying elements
from Donald Trump, from López Obrador, from
other politicians and then turning it into his
own little Salvadoran variety of it. So none of
this ever exists in the void. And that's why it's
really important for everybody to understand
that what's happening in your country will be
happening in other countries. Politicians, the
public, media - we're all looking at each other.
We’re all copying things from each other and
that's why it's important to understand both
the local context and the global context.
Neil BRANDVOLD: It's a very scary time
right now in El Salvador.
SIERRA: This is Neil Brandvold.
He’s an American documentary filmmaker and
a photojournalist based in El Salvador.
His groundbreaking documentary Unforgivable
explores the romantic relationship between two
gang members in an El Salvador prison.
BRANDVOLD: Prior to the rise of Bukele,
the fear for most of us was reporting on gangs
and being killed by a gang member or working in
gang controlled territory, but that's shifted.
So now, instead of being afraid of the gangs,
the fear is of repercussions from the
government. He's dismantled the Supreme Court,
put in his own judges. With Congress,
he controls the whole Congress and is
changing the Constitution. And now, we've been
10 months in a martial law situation here where
if you report on the gangs and they interpret
that as you’re being a mouthpiece to the gangs,
according to whatever the government says that
is, it's a 10 to 15 year prison sentence for a
journalist. Nayib Bukele has humongous approval
ratings. The public believes what he says. So
the general population is really distrustful of
us. It's a mix of distrust, but also of fear of
repercussions from the government. So when we go
out to report and do stories, our access is often
limited because people are afraid to speak out
against the government on TV. So if you want to
have an idea of how bad things have gotten here
in El Salvador, the journalists that have fled,
the majority of them have fled to Mexico, which
has historically been one of the most dangerous
places to be a journalist. And will be reporting
on El Salvador from Mexico because they’re
afraid of repercussions from the government.
SIERRA: Bukele enjoys enormous popularity, and
tries to strike the image of a young, hip leader
- wearing leather jackets and baseball caps,
and wielding a savvy command of social media. In
fact, Bukele enjoys 4 million Instagram followers,
and 5 million twitter followers, and his habit
of attacking critics online has earned him the
moniker “the millennial dictator.”
BRANDVOLD: He doesn't allow
access to journalists to interview him. The only
interviews he's given since he has taken power
has been with Tucker Carlson at Fox News.
Part of it's restricting access. Then also,
demonizing the media on social media. He's very
aggressive through Twitter, where he's just
constantly attacking journalists to the point of
calling journalists "gang members" and harassing
them and scaring them out of the country. But
that's where people are getting their news. One
thing that's interesting here in El Salvador, for
instance, is the majority of people rely on news
that comes from government-run media because
those are the only media that's reaching rural
communities or people that don't have access.
So, the only thing they're hearing is what the
government is telling them that they should
be believing, and then constantly demonizing
the opposition or anyone that speaks out or
says anything different than the party line.
SIERRA: But aside from Bukele’s influencer
status, he has also achieved a feat many thought
impossible. In March of 2022, Bukele officially
declared a “war on gangs” and since then murders
in El Salvador have dropped 56 percent. The
change reinforced his popularity enormously.
Critics, however, note that in the process, El
Salvador attained the highest incarceration rate
in the world, with about 2 percent of its adult
population living behind bars. Human rights groups
have raised concerns about wrongful arrests
and abusive conditions in prison facilities,
but these criticisms have done nothing
to jeopardize Bukele’s popularity.
BRANDVOLD: It's really interesting. I think a lot
of people internationally would never grasp how
bad the situation under gangs were in El Salvador.
It was incredibly violent. The highest homicide
rate in the entire world outside of Syria for
years. They were just incredibly violent. The
people that live there just suffered horribly.
I covered the crime scene in homicide beat for
years, going out at night and we would be bouncing
from murder, to murder, to murder. Horrible,
horrible murders. And the general public, when
he came in and he said, "I'm going to dismantle
the gangs. I don't care about human rights. Throw
everyone in the prison." In the last 10 months,
he's arrested 60,000 people. 60,000 people that
have no access to a lawyer, to see a judge,
or any habeas corpus. And the general population I
think was so fed up with living under the fist of
these really violent, horrible gang members that
would extort them, would murder them, would kidnap
their kids, that they're just like, "Let him do
what he is doing." And you speak to people and
they're like, "He's dismantled the gangs," which
is largely true. For the most part, the gangs
are not operating like they used to. So I think
your average person says, "Keep going, Bukele."
He's illegally, unconstitutionally running for a
reelection, he's announced, and will probably win
by a very large majority. And it's been kind of
this handoff of security and democracy. When you
look at democracy in El Salvador, it’s this very
short-lived democracy. The Civil War ended in the
'90s. We're talking like 30 years of democracy
- that's been a lot of failed governments. Each
party has been super corrupt. And they're just
looking at this, "We want security." So they
just shut us off or attack us in the streets.
It's made it very difficult to feel like you're
making a change because the average person in
El Salvador just doesn't want to hear it.
SIERRA: Can you tell me a little bit more
about how Bukele has made it hard for you
and for other journalists to report the news?
BRANDVOLD: Access used to be very open prior to
Bukele. I mean, we were spending months in the
prisons. I had access to the forensics teams,
which is really important here to be able
to get really good numbers on homicides and
anything like that. Before Bukele was president
I interviewed him in his campaign many times and
it was very open. As journalists, we all knew
that things were going to change when he came
to power. And they changed really quickly.
It went from pretty much open access where
you could go with a forensics team, or ride
along with the police, or go into the jails,
to absolutely no information, no access. And then,
it spiraled into we found that journalists' phones
were all hacked. We were getting Pegasus. Over
30 journalists here were infected with Pegasus.
And that's just a small amount of the spyware
they've been using against journalists.
Al Jazeera English: Pegasus has been used by
governments around the world to spy on dissidents
and journalists via their mobile phones.
60 Minutes: We look specifically at a
controversial Israeli called the NSO Group that
says it developed a hacking tool that can break
into just about any smartphone on Earth.
Al Jazeera English: What’s particularly
concerning about this spyware is, unlike
most infections where you have to click
on something or do something,
it just gets into your phone.
SIERRA: Journalists have always worried about
being spied on, but the threat of invasive
spyware is unique to the current generation. Long
story short, once a phone has been compromised by
Pegasus, everything on it can be viewed, including
calls, texts, location, and recorded materials.
It’s a perfect tool for would-be authoritarians.
BRANDVOLD: So, we know that El Salvador purchased
it from this Israeli company, Pegasus. They
have access to basically everything on your
phone. So they know where you're going, and they
can access it. They have access to all of your
photos, your contacts, your microphone, your
camera, everything. They have full access.
SIERRA: That's pretty scary. Yeah.
BRANDVOLD: Yeah. Very scary. But speaking
with contacts in the US State Department, we know
that that's just a small portion of the amount of
spyware and hacking abilities that the government
is capable of. I mean, the amount of security
measures that we have to take as journalists in
El Salvador, has just - it's skyrocketed. Using
different apps to scan our phones to see if it's
infected. But then also knowing most likely the
government has access to everything on our phone
and just communicating in a way with the idea that
the government's listening.
HOOTSEN: Another
thing that's very important to point out here
is that Pegasus is only one kind of spyware.
It's only one of dozens that we know are being
used by governments across the globe. We're not
nearly done investigating Pegasus, and, in the
meantime, how many other kinds of spyware that
are much harder to detect may have already been
bought by the Mexican government and by other
governments in Latin America?
SIERRA: As technology evolves,
the risk for journalists gets even greater.
Hostile rhetoric circulating online can easily
translate into very real violence amongst the
public. And as some leaders in Latin America
further limit access to independent information,
citizens are being led astray by propaganda that
dictates how they should view the press.
This is certainly the case in Mexico and El
Salvador, and echoes of the problem can be
heard from Eastern Europe to South Asia,
and even in the United States. A strong free
press is, after all, a hard thing to build,
and an easy thing to lose, and it is an eternal
thorn in the side of those who would establish
a monopoly on power. Even now, despite these
global setbacks, journalists are still reporting,
finding new ways to circumvent obstacles, and
hoping that soon they may be able to do their
jobs without a target on their backs.
ZISSIS: I have to say that it's incredibly
inspiring to think about journalists who want
to report in spite of all of these threats,
especially because if we're going to go on a local
level, we know that they're not going to be paid
well. They could be risking their lives, they
could be risking threats and violence against
their family members. We've seen cases where
journalists have been attacked or killed in
front of family members. It's really frightening.
How do you create the conditions for people to
want to become journalists? And the problem is,
this is exactly what weakens the democracy in
the country because people don't want to. Why
would you do that? Why would you put yourself
in harm's way? It makes it all the more inspiring
for those who continue to try to report and try
to report independently. But it certainly creates
the conditions for, in many parts of the country,
where journalists face these kinds of threats
from local authorities, from local police,
from local crime groups, because the threats come
from all different sides that we have a lack of
information, we have a lack of information
about what's going on. And so it's a real
reminder of they're holding a government
accountable that might not be able to be
held accountable in any other way.
HOOTSEN: I'm actually an optimist in
that sense. If I weren't an optimist I wouldn't be
able to do our job. I think fatalism is fatal in
advocating for press freedom. People still want a
critical press and every really good journalistic
investigation immediately gets a huge bump, it
gets a huge response both on social media and
beyond. And that shows me that ultimately people
will miss it when it's gone. There is a hunger
for press freedom. There's a hunger for good
journalism and there is good sense amongst the
general public that press freedom is something
that needs to be protected. And that there are
still a lot of spaces that are worth defending
and that will continue to be defended.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode and
more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters and
take a look at the show notes. If you ever have
any questions or suggestions or just want to chat,
email us at whyitmatters@cfr.org or
hit us up on Twitter at @CFR_org.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations. The opinions expressed
on the show are solely that of the
guests, not of CFR, which takes no
institutional positions on matters of policy.
The show is produced by Asher Ross and me,
Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer is Markus
Zakaria. Our associate podcast producer is
Molly McAnany. Our interns this semester
are Emily Pace and Rebecca Rottenberg.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Noah Berman, Kali Robinson, and Diana Roy.
Our theme music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
We’d also like to thank Richard Haass,
Jeff Reinke, and our co-creator Jeremy Sherlick.
You can subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts,
Spotify, Stitcher, YouTube or
wherever you get your audio.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle
Sierra signing off. See you around!